[Music]
on this Monday night Canadian doctors
send out an SOS
hospitals crowded with sick children we
need to protect each other the pleas for
Mass mandates at ottawa's remedy for a
medicine shortage
a man in Quebec accused of spying for
Beijing this is the first time this
charge has been laid in Canada as the
Chinese and American Presidents hold a
rare face-to-face
gratitude and grief in Ukraine
best heroes of our country cautious
optimism after a key City's Liberation
and navigating life at Sea there's a bit
of a Groundhog Day the small Comforts on
this big Navy ship
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with what so many parents of young
children already know kids are getting
sick with alarming frequency and many
emergency rooms in this country are
overwhelmed the surge in respiratory
viruses flu RSV and covid is sweeping
across Canada today Ontario's Top
Doctors strongly recommended masks be
worn in all indoor public settings
Quebec is recommending mask wearing too
but no jurisdiction has returned to mask
mandates that's what some doctors are
demanding hell Canada did announce today
it's importing children's pain and fever
medication to alleviate the shortage in
pharmacies and is asking parents not to
hoard it Mike jerlay has our top story
tonight
it's a Rite of fall for Pediatric icus
to be pushed to their limits both the
Children's Hospital of eastern Ontario
at over 200 percent capacity and
Toronto's overwhelmed sick kids hospital
canceling surgeries the medical
community is putting up the White Flag
we need to protect our health system we
need to protect each other and it's
really getting back to all of those
Basics we need a reboot Dr Kieran Moore
wants a return to masking as a
recommendation not mandatory because the
threat has changed this isn't coveted
that's affecting our children rather
it's the flu and RSV a respiratory
infection that usually presents itself
as a moderate cold for which there is no
vaccine even though doctors insist masks
will help two years of pandemic
sacrifices make it a tough sell we all
know that mass don't work we do of
course I think it's it's a gimmick it's
in order to put people to sleep again
there's no gimmick as far as Lauren
Dempsey knows her son George was
admitted to sick kids four and a half
weeks ago with RSV and he's had to be
intubated twice it is insane he's clear
of RSV now but before he goes home his
mother is fighting to get him a
treatment he's previously had as a
high-risk child that would reduce his
chance of returning to a hospital where
the cafeteria is being used for overflow
patients you don't want to leave your
room because you're afraid you're gonna
part of me catch something
and if they're doing the best they can
so how'd this happen doctors point to
staffing issues that have plagued the
system for years and empty medicine
shelves and pharmacies have given
parents few options but to go to the ER
problem the federal government says will
get better in the coming weeks just a
few hours ago we announced an important
importation of a few months additional
supply of energy for children which will
make a big difference in the ability of
children to be cared in Canada care is
one thing say Top Doctors but they'd
like to see people put more effort into
preventing the spread in the first place
the impact is really meaningful for some
family and now many families and I think
we remember you know the human face of
this
it's crushing Mike drolet Global News
Toronto
Espionage charges have been laid against
a former employee at Hydro Quebec 35
year old yushang Wang faces four charges
it's alleged he stole Trade Secrets From
the provincial energy provider to
benefit the People's Republic of China
while he was working at a as a
researcher for hydro Quebec Mike
Armstrong reports on the investigation
what else the RCMP allege and what
happens next
the RCMP isn't saying much about its
investigation only that it started in
August with a tip from Hydro Quebec and
wrapped up Monday morning with an arrest
at the suspect's home 35-year-old Yu
Shang Wang will appear in court Tuesday
Mr Wang was charged with Espionage for
obtaining trade secrets in the course of
his duties with Hydro Quebec according
to hydro Quebec Wang was a researcher at
this facility just outside Montreal the
center of excellence in transportation
electrification and energy storage
actress says its security teams did an
initial investigation realized the scope
of the problem and called police Wang
was cut off from the company's research
and fired according to his online
profiles Wang had worked for hydro since
October of 2016. prior to that he'd
worked at the University of Arkansas and
the Queen Mary University of London he
was educated in China now what he's
alleged to have done in Canada is passed
on Research from Hydro Quebec to a
Chinese University and other Chinese
research centers he reportedly published
scientific articles and submitted
patents in association with this foreign
actor
rather than with Hydro Quebec I think
there is a blessing in disguise Michelle
Juno Katsuya is a former senior
intelligence officer with Canada's spy
agency cesus he says the arrest is a
good sign people are being vigilant and
also a warning to others who aren't
economic Espionage costs Canada he says
between 100 and 120 billion dollars a
year stealing intellectual property is
not only done by the Chinese uh many
many many countries and even friends are
doing it the uh Hydro Quebec is
considered by the RCMP an at-risk sector
meaning it's work and research is of
strategic interest and to be protected
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal
and China's president Xi Jinping met
with the American president for three
hours today ahead of the G20 Summit it's
their first in-person meeting since
becoming leaders of their respective
countries they agreed to work to repair
the relationship Biden says the U.S is
not looking for conflict but he wants
China to as he says comply with the
international rules of the road prime
minister Justin Trudeau is also at the
G20 where the war in Ukraine is top of
the agenda at issue whether Western
countries can convince Russian allies to
take a stronger stance against Vladimir
Putin but there's a risk that divisions
over the war could end up splitting up
the group as Mackenzie gray reports from
Bali Canada is pushing to further
isolate Russia
Russia's brutal war in Ukraine is
creating food and energy crises it's
disrupting Supply chains and raising the
cost of living even before the G20
starts the prime minister is attempting
to push the agenda towards focusing on
Vladimir Putin and his government is
backing up the tough talk by announcing
a half billion dollar military aid
package to support the ukrainians but
that new money was short on details our
goal is to make sure that the troops in
Ukraine on the ground have access to
additional Military Support soon this is
the last thing the host of the g21 had
announced with Indonesia attempting to
get Western countries to soften their
language on Ukraine in a bid to try and
find consensus around the G20 table with
Russian allies I'm sure they also think
that there's really no realistic
Prospect of the G20 coming to a
agreement on the situation in Ukraine
Russia and China of course in India as
well would probably rather not have any
particular statement in the final
communique on that one of those allies
China whose president Xi Jinping met
with U.S President Joe Biden in person
for the first time since Biden took
office
the high stakes meeting lasted three
hours with China promising to promptly
follow up and implement the important
common understandings reached we're
going to compete vigorously but I'm not
looking for conflict I'm looking to
manage this competition responsibly
and I want to make sure make sure that
every country abides by the
international rules of the road the
leaders of France and Australia are also
getting a one-on-one with Xi Jinping as
for Canada the foreign affairs minister
wouldn't say if they even asked for a
meeting our goal is always to make sure
that we have a dialogue even on
difficult issues Canada also sanctioned
23 Russians involved in the arrest of a
prominent Russian opposition leader and
late Monday night Russia pushed back
they sanctioned a hundred Canadians
including author Margaret Atwood actor
Jim Carrey and her own Chief political
correspondent David Aiken Donna all
right Mackenzie gray in Bali Indonesia
tonight thanks
foreign
[Applause]
moving moment today Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski singing the National
Anthem during a surprise visit to the
newly liberated city of Curson
zielinski called the moment heartwarming
and said despite the destruction of the
number of dead ukrainians have proved it
is impossible to kill Ukraine Russian
troops retreated from the city last
Friday a move seen as a major setback
for Russia and its almost nine-month war
on Ukraine Redman Shannon reports on
what it could signal
another moment of joy in her son a newly
liberated city that has had little to
smile about for more than eight months
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
hopeful but realistic in his answer this
long way difficult way because
this this
to the best heroes of our country we're
ready for peace but our peace for our
gathering is all our country all our
territory in his short visit he thanked
soldiers
and the remaining residents of the
regional Capital left without power or
running water and still under Russian
shelling according to Ukraine zielinski
says NATO supplies deserve some of the
credit to all this Victory is possible
when on when all the world is around
Ukraine he says there is evidence of
more than 400 war crimes in nearby areas
abandoned by Russia as residents enjoy
the end of occupation they accuse
Russian soldiers of looting a city the
Kremlin supposedly regarded as its own
they have stolen everything they have
stolen our trolley buses our bosses our
ambulance chances at the G20 Vladimir
Putin was a no-show sending Sergey
lavrov instead a report that the foreign
minister was admitted to hospital in
Bali quickly dismissed by him on social
media
as ever blaming the West for sowing fake
news
meanwhile in Turkey Russia's spy Chief
Sergey narishkin met with the head of
the CIA William Burns the highest
profile in-person talks between Moscow
and Washington since the War Began they
reportedly discussed managing the risk
of a nuclear conflict Redmond Shannon
Global News London
countering threats from within coming up
criticism the Canadian military isn't
doing enough to fight white supremacy
a new report released today by the
National Security and intelligence
agency found white supremacy poses an
active threat to and within the Canadian
military the review also concluded the
Canadian Forces National
counterintelligence unit's ability to
monitor the threat is limited Eric
Sorensen looked into the findings and
the recommendations Eric
Donna the review focused on the Canadian
Forces National counterintelligence unit
and its domestic efforts to identify
Insider threats it found there has been
inadequate integration with other
security teams in the defense department
and that the unit has not been up to the
task of countering extremism in spite of
multiple reviews the counterintelligence
unit has been the subject of 10 internal
studies in the last quarter Century all
found the unit suffered from resource
and policy limitations resulting in an
inability to fully meet its mandate this
review does not significantly depart
from these previous assessments Former
Defense Minister harjit sajan undertook
a review that found the military has not
done enough to identify and prevent
extremism white supremacy scandalized
the Canadian military almost 30 years
ago when the Canadian Airborne regiment
was disbanded after some members beat a
Somali teenager to death more recently a
former engineer in the Canadian Army
Reserve Patrick Matthews was sentenced
to nine years in prison in the U.S for
his role in a plot to attack a pro-gun
rally in Virginia allegedly to instigate
a race war
the National Security and intelligence
review agency says in its report that
white supremacist groups seek out
individuals with prior military training
and encourages others to enlist in the
military to gain access to military
tactics and equipment
while the agency found that white
supremacy poses an active
counterintelligence threat this
government like previous governments has
not said how it will fix the problem on
top of that the revelations could
further discourage recruitment at a time
when demands on the Canadian Armed
Forces are only increasing Donna right
Eric Sorensen in Ottawa thank you we are
getting our first look at the
discussions that took place in cabinet
before the federal emergencies Act was
invoked in February the commission
reviewing use of the ACT is hearing from
senior bureaucrats who advised Federal
politicians among them the deputy
minister at the Department of Public
Safety Rob Stewart he testified today he
was concerned invoking the ACT might
cause more harm than good and possibly
inside bigger more violent
demonstrations that didn't happen
instead Stewart says the threat of
removing trucks driver's licenses and
insurance was more effective than
expected
others have come forward to say that
this was a tool that they in the end
used and found useful
tomorrow is another big day RCMP
commissioner Brenda lucky will take the
stand at the inquiry
Canada wants to make history on the moon
plans were announced this morning to
build the country's first lunar rover
the design and building of the space
vehicle is being led by canadensis
Aerospace the federal government says
the goal is to find water ice in the
lunar soil a critical resource of humans
are to colonize the moon the Rover could
be sent to space as early as 2026.
Republican ruminations ahead the tough
decisions facing the GOP following
disappointment in the midterms
the dust still hasn't settled from last
week's midterm elections in the U.S we
know Democrats will keep control of the
Senate but the house remains up for
grabs several races are too close to
call ballots are still being counted and
looming over that the prospect of former
president Donald Trump making another
run for the White House Jackson prosco
reports
in Bali a long-distance Victory lap by
President Joe Biden the American people
prove once again that democracy is Who
We Are
Democrats big wins came after most of
Donald Trump's hand-picked candidates
went down in defeat taking with them
Trump's lies about the 2020 election
there's a strong rejection of election
deniers at every level from those
seeking to lead to our states
and those seeking to serve in Congress
the Searing rebuke has weakened the
former president standing raising
questions about a trump comeback in 2024
on the eve of his planned campaign
announcement the president tweets Mike
Pence didn't have the courage to do what
should have been done
speaking to ABC News a former vice
president Mike Pence seized the moment
openly criticizing his former boss for
the events of January 6th it angered me
I mean the president's words were
Reckless
it's clear he decided to be part of the
problem behind the scenes some
Republicans are reportedly pushing Trump
to delay his campaign launch what we
gotta do
we got to get out of vote especially
with the senate race in Georgia between
Herschel Walker and Rafael Warnock
headed to a December runoff
maybe his announcement and his
prominence in the campaign maybe that's
another bad sign for republicans in a in
a runoff situation
newly elected members of Congress have
already started orientation at the
Capitol very excited yeah yeah I'm
taking uh taking a piece of History
right now but nothing can prepare rookie
Republicans for the turmoil that awaits
the party is not just split over Trump
but also what to do about leaders like
Mitch McConnell and Kevin McCarthy who
oversaw the party's disappointing
election performance
their Fates along with control of the
house are still undecided Jackson prosco
Global News Washington
funerals are being held in Istanbul
Turkey for the victims of a bombing on a
busy shopping street Sunday
six people were killed two members from
Three Families including a
three-year-old girl who was shopping
with her father mourners have placed
flowers at the site of the bombing no
one has claimed responsibility the
Turkish government has blamed the pkk a
Kurdish terrorist organization it denies
any involvement dozens of people have
been arrested including a woman who
police say was sitting on a bench in the
area and left minutes before the
explosion
sailing the Arctic sea next a look at
life on board one of Canada's largest
navy ships
[Music]
members of the Royal Canadian Navy are
used to spending months at sea but
sailing the Arctic Ocean is unlike
anything most have experienced before
they are far from home almost entirely
cut off from the outside world as they
Patrol the far north of the country well
earlier this fall Jeff Semple joined the
crew on board the newly commissioned
hmcs Margaret Brook and he gives us a
rare look at life at sea
Sailors on hmcs Margaret Brook are
responding to an emergency announcement
a fire in the engine room on board the
Arctic Icebreaker last cycle okay this
is a drill one of several held without
warning every week on the Navy vessel to
keep these Sailors on their toes the
crew Spends months at Sea patrolling the
Canadian Arctic it's definitely a
different and unique way of life even
for seasoned Sailors the Arctic feels
cut off from the outside world limited
internet or phone means little contact
with loved ones back home it's always
difficult leaving home for an extended
period of time the ship's executive
officer has a 20 month old son and this
picture probably was taken in April or
so he spent the past two months away at
Sea I'm a new dad so it adds kind of A
New Perspective to it a new side to
things going away the Margaret Brook is
part of a new class of Arctic Patrol
ships some of the biggest ships to be
built by the Canadian Navy in 50 years
years it's a hundred meters long there
are eight decks here but I can still
feel at times like a little bit of a
tight squeeze so for that reason there
are plenty of spots on board where
Sailors can stretch their sea legs from
the lounge to the gym there's also a
doctor's office treating a range of
ailments including the most common which
we experienced first hand seasickness
there are some people that are just
chronic seasick here we go
Stephen Clark is in charge of morale he
says one of the most important rooms is
the cafeteria definitely on a ship
morale runs through the galley offering
a different menu every day of the week
especially on this type of operation
there's a bit of a groundhog day right
now
just anything to do something a little
different to break up the monotony in
the daily routine number three the type
of Pastor that takes his name from
Italian little worms that includes
trivia night crib tournaments and the
fan favorite Sundays on Sundays served
by the ship's senior officers a tasty
tradition except when the commander
accidentally mixes up the caramel with
the barbecue sauce
[Music]
for the ship's 65 Sailors far from home
the crew feels like a second family
living and working together to navigate
one of the most remote regions on Earth
Jeff Semple global news on board hmcs
Margaret Brook
Sundays on Sunday I like that idea that
is global national for this Monday I'm
Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada is
the snowy rural Municipality of Hanover
southeast of Winnipeg we'd love to see
your Canada please email it to viewers
at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
foreign
[Music]